[Música]
hoy vengo a contarles una paradoja él es
juan pero hoy no les voy a contar sobre
la vida de juan les voy a contar sobre
lo que la gente que vive alrededor de
juan piensa de juana la gente piensa que
juan está un poco perdido piensa que no
sabe muy bien para dónde va su vida
piensa que solamente le gusta la
diversión el sexo
la moda la tecnología piensa que es
inmaduro la gente que está alrededor de
juan piensa que juan es un delincuente
potencial que es violento que no está
capacitado para ayudar a su familia y
mucho menos para ayudar a su país en
síntesis la gente cree que juan no tiene
futuro
prejuicios duros prejuicios nosotros
hicimos recientemente en unicef un
estudio de imagen sobre los adolescentes
en perú y nos dimos cuenta que la
mayoría de gente piensa así sobre los
adolescentes y lo grave es que nosotros
no nos relacionamos con quien tenemos
enfrente nos relacionamos con quien
creemos que tenemos enfrente entonces
imagínense cómo se relacionará uno con
una persona que cree que es delincuente
que solamente piensa en tener sexo y que
no tiene futuro
lo realmente paradójico es que no vemos
a la persona que tenemos enfrente una
persona que está en un momento de su
desarrollo vital absolutamente central
los neurocientíficos nos han dicho que
hay dos momentos en el desarrollo de las
personas en donde nuestro cerebro tiene
como unos picos especiales en donde se
complejiza uno es durante la primera
infancia y otro es durante la
adolescencia durante la adolescencia
nuestro cerebro cerebro se reorganiza
las conexiones neuronales que nos sirven
o que no hemos usado mucho se deshacen
para darle espacio a otras que sean más
útiles es como un edificio que está
cableado para conectar todo con todo y
en determinado momento ese edificio se
reorganiza su cableado se eliminan los
cables que nos sirven y nacen nuevos
cables para conectar el piso más
importante del edificio
ustedes saben cuál es el piso más
importante de nuestro edificio cerebral
es la parte frontal del cerebro
la parte frontal del cerebro es la que
se desarrolla durante la adolescencia y
ahí se vuelven a crear nuevos cables y
nuevas conexiones neuronales pero de qué
se encarga la parte central y frontal
del cerebro la parte frontal del cerebro
se encarga por ejemplo de tomar
decisiones por eso es que a los
adolescentes les cuesta tanto trabajo
decidirse si lo que les gusta es esto o
si lo que les gusta es lo otro y por eso
seguramente nosotros pensamos que ellos
están como medio perdidos la parte
frontal del cerebro se encarga de
planear las tareas y los tiempos yo no
sé si ustedes han hablado de tiempos con
un adolescente yo tengo dos y me pasa
todo el tiempo tienes que estar a las
cuatro y media en una cita son las
cuatro y quince tienes que tener todo
listo ay mamá tú si quieres exagerada y
pasa todo el tiempo les cuesta planear
la parte frontal del cerebro se encarga
también de la memoria prospectiva esa
que nos permite acordarnos después de
algo que tenemos que hacer llamar al
papá ya la mamá cuando llegue a la casa
del amigo
también se les olvidó y la parte frontal
del cerebro se encarga de controlar los
comportamientos riesgosos y de valorar
esos riesgos entonces por ejemplo a los
adolescentes les cuesta trabajo
controlar la ira la impulsividad y les
cuesta trabajo ver los riesgos como los
vemos nosotros
lo paradójico es que los
neurocientíficos nos han dicho que el
cerebro tiene una característica
maravillosa que es la plasticidad es
decir que se crea y se configura
dependiendo de los estímulos externos
que tengamos dependiendo de las
interacciones que tengamos con los
adolescentes dependiendo de qué tan
enriquecidos son los escenarios en donde
ellos crecen dependiendo de nuestros
prejuicios
y lo grave de los prejuicios no es
solamente que condicionan nuestra
interacción con los adolescentes es que
seguramente también están definiendo el
acceso a oportunidades a bienes y
servicios públicos para los adolescentes
si nosotros comparamos por ejemplo el
beneficio o los accesos a servicios que
tienen adolescentes con respecto a otros
grupos de población nos vamos a dar
cuenta que ellos tienen menos
oportunidades por ejemplo en el seguro
integrado de salud en el grupo de
adolescentes hay por lo menos medio
millón menos de asegurados que en el
grupo más pequeño y si nosotros
comparamos la capacidad de comprensión
lectora de un niño de segundo de
primaria con la capacidad lectora de un
adolescente de segundo de secundaria nos
vamos a dar cuenta que en el primer
grupo cinco de cada diez entiende lo que
lee en el segundo solamente dos de cada
diez entiende lo que lee y lo mismo le
pasa a los jóvenes en el 2016
perú cerró con una tasa de desempleo del
4 por ciento la tasa de desempleo
juvenil fue del 12%
a veces más entonces les estamos dando
menos oportunidades que a otros grupos
de población y no quiere decir que esos
grupos les tengamos que dar menos quiere
decir que a los adolescentes les tenemos
que dar al menos lo mismo pero también
le estamos quitando oportunidades a los
adolescentes cuando no desarrollamos
políticas específicas para el momento de
la vida en el que están por ejemplo les
estamos robando a las adolescentes que
quedan embarazadas muchas oportunidades
una adolescente que queda embarazada muy
posiblemente va a abandonar la escuela
el ingreso
al trabajo va a ser más difícil y va a
ganar menos recursos 13 por ciento de
las embarazadas tras adolescentes el año
pasado estaban embarazadas o eran madres
y si revisamos esa proporción en la
amazonía 30% 2000 niñas de 10 a 15 años
dieron a luz el año pasado
les estamos robando oportunidades y les
estamos robando oportunidades también a
las adolescentes que han sido abusadas
sexualmente 34 por ciento de las
adolescentes entre 12 y 17 años han sido
abusadas sexualmente les estamos robando
su dignidad les estamos robando la
capacidad de confiar en los otros de
confiar en ellas mismas
y la severidad de estos problemas no es
lo más grave es su potencial magnitud
ustedes saben cuántos adolescentes hay
en perú en perú hay 3.5 millones de
adolescentes en américa latina' 110
millones de adolescentes en el mundo 1.2
billones de adolescentes es el momento
de la historia de la humanidad en que
más adolescentes y jóvenes ha habido
desde 1950 hasta la fecha se ha más que
duplicado el número de adolescentes y
jóvenes en el mundo y eso me da pie para
contarles que estamos atravesando un
momento especial en la humanidad es una
transición demográfica que se conoce
como el bono demográfico que es cuando
la población potencialmente productiva
aumenta en comparación con la población
potencialmente dependiente
imaginemos los que estamos en una
estación de tren a esta estación de tren
solamente entran tres trenes y pasan más
o menos cada 50 o 60 años el primer tren
ya pasó venía jalado por algunos
adolescentes y jóvenes pero cargaba
millones y millones de niños algunos
adultos y algunos viejos la expectativa
de vida de los que manejaban el tren era
corta ese tren no llegó muy lejos
el segundo tren está entrando en este
momento en la estación es un tren que
viene jalado también por adolescentes y
jóvenes pero por millones de
adolescentes y jóvenes y el peso
proporcional que llevan es mucho menor
algunos adultos algunos viejos algunos
niños el tercer tren entra más o menos
en 50 o 60 años a la estación vienen al
lado por algunos adolescentes pero el
peso que jala es enorme vienen miles de
millones de adultos y de viejos que tren
creen ustedes que lleguen más rápido y
mejor a la estación el segundo tren que
tren está entrando en este momento a la
estación el segundo tren más nos vale a
nosotros garantizar que los que van
manejando ese tren tengan todo lo que
necesitan tener salud educación
capacidad de innovar capacidad de
resolver los problemas que se van a
encontrar por el camino les conviene a
ellos y nos conviene a nosotros
si ven la paradoja en la que estamos por
un lado la plasticidad del cerebro
dependiendo de cómo nos relacionamos de
cómo interactuamos con los adolescentes
ese cerebro se va a desarrollar bien o
se va a desarrollar mal y por el otro
lado el bono demográfico una oportunidad
en la humanidad única si este tren pasa
el segundo pasará en 200 años o lo
cogemos ahora o se nos fue el tren pero
ustedes deben estarse preguntando ven y
yo qué hago para ayudar a que el tren
llegue a un buen destino el destino por
ejemplo de la prosperidad el destino de
la inclusión de la democracia
yo llevo 27 años de mi vida trabajando
para que los niños las niñas y los
adolescentes vivan mejor porque en
realidad estoy convencida que es la
única manera de que la humanidad viva
mejor y el trabajador del sector público
y también desde el sector privado y
desde la cooperación internacional y
llevo mucho tiempo estudiando y
reflexionando sobre lo que sirve y lo
que nos sirve para desencadenar ese
potencial ilimitado
en los adolescentes
y si tuviera hoy que resumir mi
experiencia para compartirla con ustedes
en algunas ideas sencillas les diría que
hay tres experiencias que todos los
adolescentes deberían vivir y que
nosotros sin importar quiénes seamos o
lo que hagamos podemos ofrecerles
la primera experiencia en la experiencia
del reconocimiento recae sobre nosotros
la acción de reconocerlos reconocerlos
volverlos a conocer entender que ahí hay
un legítimo otro que piensa distinto que
siente diferente que tiene unas
emociones y unos sueños distintos a los
nuestros y que sus opiniones son al
menos tan válidas como las nuestras
reconocerlos también tiene que ver con
admirar los componer nos unas gafas que
nos permitan ver las cualidades de los
adolescentes por ejemplo la creatividad
por ejemplo la indignación que les
produce la injusticia o como por ejemplo
las dudas que ellos tienen sobre lo
instituido son unas gafas que nos
permiten ver que el cambio que ellos
representan no es una amenaza es al
contrario nuestra gran oportunidad la
segunda experiencia que todos los
adolescentes deberían vivir es el
respeto un respeto sin transacciones no
es yo te respeto si tú me respetas es yo
te respeto siempre para que tú aprendas
a respetarme
y respetarlos no es dejarlos hacer lo
que quieran respetarlos es tomarlo
seriamente es involucrarlos en las
decisiones que los afectan respetarlos
también es no violentar los ustedes no
se imaginan cómo es de fácil para los
adultos traspasar la línea el borde de
la dignidad de las adolescentes el
ministerio público nos dice que el 76
por ciento de las víctimas de abuso
sexual en los últimos cinco años en perú
son niñas y adolescentes el 76 por
ciento
un constitucionalista muy famoso
latinoamericano reconocido por sus
aportes a los derechos humanos carlos
gaviria que ya apareció dijo una vez en
una sentencia los adultos debemos tratar
a los niños ya los adolescentes como si
los quisiéramos como si los quisiéramos
para resaltar la responsabilidad ética
que tenemos los adultos de sobreponernos
a nuestras emociones y a nuestros
prejuicios para respetarlos
la tercera experiencia que todos los
adolescentes deberían vivir las
oportunidades oportunidades de
sobrevivir oportunidades de conocer
contextos diferentes oportunidades de
conocer gente oportunidades de innovar
pero lo interesante de las oportunidades
es que no puede ser una tienen que hacer
muchas porque la adolescencia es un
período corto de tiempo se acaba
entonces tenemos que llenar ese periodo
de muchas oportunidades para que ese
potencial efectivamente se desarrolle
entonces si tuviera que resumir mi
experiencia y lo que yo creo que sirve
para los adolescentes en una fórmula les
diría que la fórmula es reconocimiento
más respeto más oportunidades elevado a
la potencia infinito
pero adicionemos una expresión más a
esta fórmula x todos también he
aprendido en mi experiencia laboral que
solo nadie puede el sector privado solo
no puede el sector público solo no puede
las familias solas no pueden todos
nosotros ustedes se imaginan que todos
los que estamos hoy en esta sala
hiciéramos algo diferente por los
adolescentes sin importar si son
empresarios académicos funcionarios
públicos artistas medios de comunicación
si todos hiciéramos algo diferente
me pregunto yo por ejemplo si los
maestros y los directores de escuela
pudieran tomarse en serio esto el
reconocimiento de los adolescentes y
permitirles que participaran en el
gobierno escolar pero no para tocar el
timbre del recreo o para repartir el
último boletín sino para definir las
normas de convivencia escolar o qué tal
sin más docentes se preocuparan por
ofrecer a los adolescentes una educación
sexual integral de calidad
ustedes se imaginan que todos los
funcionarios públicos que están hoy aquí
lleguen el lunes a su oficina pensando
qué más puedo hacer para los
adolescentes como cambio una política
como asignó un presupuesto como mejor un
servicio para los adolescentes
pero vayamos un poquito más allá que
necesitamos saber para tomar mejores
decisiones para los adolescentes y
entonces se imaginan que todos los
investigadores que todos los académicos
se dedicarán a duplicar o a triplicar el
conocimiento que hoy tenemos sobre los
adolescentes para tomar mejor decisiones
y si los empresarios dijeran me
comprometo a ofrecerle el primer empleo
digno a todos los jóvenes del perú o a
financiar sus innovaciones oa promover
su asociatividad imaginémonos que los
artistas quisieran acompañar esa
necesidad infinita de expresión que
tienen los adolescentes hoy imaginémonos
por ejemplo que los medios de
comunicación por cada noticia mala que
salga sobre una adolescente van a sacar
cinco buenas a lo mejor así cambiamos
los prejuicios que tenemos sobre ellos
pero mirándolos esta mañana ustedes yo
puedo suponer que aquí somos varios las
madres y los padres de familia de
adolescentes
qué tal si nos tomáramos en serio esto
del respeto y miráramos a los ojos a
nuestros hijos y les dijéramos que su
adolescencia nos genera miedo que muchas
veces no tenemos idea que hacer pero que
aún así estamos dispuestos a escucharlos
para cambiar nuestros puntos de vista
después de haber escuchado sus posturas
y sus sueños
y eso me permite cerrar con ustedes esta
ecuación formulemos la completa la
primera parte de la ecuación el primer
postulado es la adolescencia es un
período clave de la vida de los seres
humanos la segunda es el bono
demográfico o cogemos el tren o se nos
va respeto reconocimiento afecto
oportunidades elevado a la potencia
infinito multiplicado por todos ustedes
saben en qué resultado esto resulta en
un juan reconocido en un juan respetado
en un juan lleno de oportunidades hoy y
lleno de futuro y resulta también en
nuestro tren a todo vapor
[Aplausos]